we wanted to bring out a group of
speakers and really talk about some of
the more exciting and encouraging cases
in the space and one of the most
exciting and encouraging cases in that
space
it comes from Brazil and we are very
lucky to have Karolina Rossini coming to
join us she's a Brazilian lawyer who's
worked on intellectual property open
knowledge all sorts of internet and
transformation issues over the last
dozen years I got to know her as a
fellow at the Berkman Center foreigner
in society she's now the head of
international work for public knowledge
which is an incredible advocacy group
that has been working to look at reform
of information loss around the world and
she's here with us today to talk about
Marco Saville de Internet so it's
incredibly stressful to be here right
now
because I don't know if you have noticed
some person who is actually playing
right now so why I'm here Internet 3:40
autumn with me it's a national holiday
in Brazil but anyway so I actually they
declare national holidays during the
presume games but to share with you a
little bit the experience here on what
we did the Marco Seaview to start with
Marcus view has you probably have heard
was considered a bill of rights for the
internet or in Brazil a constitution for
the internet but I gonna arrive there
soon and what is that chief
legislatively is that it sets a series
of principles and ground breaking rules
for a civil framework for the internet
so net neutrality is their freedom of
expression is their privacy is their I
think is one of the first legislations
in their world to actually tackle human
rights has the core framework for
internet regulation but it didn't arrive
there singly or in in in one year so it
actually took us more than five years to
arrive here it has not passed the mark
of our copyright law
which is being reformed for more than
eight years but almost there with all
the postponed votes and it was due to a
series of online and offline advocacy
efforts and a lot of people just think
about those right so I cannot run
through those but I think my topic here
is older my focus I would like to
discuss with you is another one
so of course Marco Seaview has gained
Twitter many times the hashtag Marco
severe microsil view now Marcos abuja
was one of the main hashtags in Brazil
in a number of occasions we got a three
million large international support from
Mozilla from access from the web we want
and from a variety of other
organizations like FF I was part of vff
at the time and we were also able to put
a series of videos through the free math
project which is a Ford Foundation
sponsored project to explain to the
common to the common folk so there
non-lawyer folks what is net neutrality
what is freedom of expression why does
this matter in the day by day so I
really call you to check these videos
very very interesting videos and for the
first time I think online advocacy also
got held in hand with offline advocacy
and it was really amazing to see the
policy the police of officers looking at
a design that was pasted in the clocks
in the Paulista Avenue saying what do we
do with it is deceive you disobedience
should I do that and they actually were
hold back from taking these things down
and this is another urban intervention
that was developed projecting the
principles of Marcos's view on the walls
of buildings in downtown San Paolo so it
was a really strong effort on using new
media an old media to really popularized
the debate around Marco Sevilla right
which i think is a little bit one of the
debates we had when you bring the next a
number of folks from society to actually
engage an inchoate engine from the
politicians where you have that tipping
point happen but I think here that they
saw a story that's the public story
right that's the sorry that we can see
in newspapers but what interest for me
has a default
the person and has a person that's
really focused on developing strategies
for a de vacas and what actually creates
impact on advocacy change I try to
understand and to engage and I was part
actually of the high school that came up
with the markussi idea was like how do
we organize and how do we train a new
generation of advocates to really engage
and really build and develop a law so
that's my main concern here and actually
if that's what it and also asked me to
focus on and what are the lessons
learned so in the very early beginning
we got the support from a very high
politician who was the head of our
Minister of Justice and with his support
we join efforts of this high school with
the Minister of Justice and we did a
first draft of the bill so even the
first draft of the bill had two phases
and was done in a collaborative platform
here it is my presentation is already in
SlideShare so you guys can have access
to that actually discussing what should
be there what are the civil rights that
should be part of that law and a second
phase where actually normal folks could
contribute writing for every paragraph
of the bill so that was a first step
when the bill was actually not even a
beauty at was just a dress and since the
beginning we really wanted to hear the
society has a whole what Internet means
for you and technology really enabled
that in a second moment when we actually
had that draft a consolidated draft that
had support we passed through a second
phase where a politician a house
representative adopt a law has its outer
and then a second politician ma long
which is there when we hear more about
adopted law has its reporter that was
really important because those
politicians when denta fight since the
early beginning had a very strong
technology portfolio in their political
portfolio and that proximity was really
important to understand so Brazil has a
platform that actually got a lot of
awards already and its founder was
actually at the candy
school for some time they developed the
democracia and Marcus if it was not the
first experiment at democracy actually
we devised our current youth and em kids
law through this platform following the
same model from definitions to
commentary to public commentary to
webcasting so there were a lot of public
consultations in the law all in abel
through this platform but also in-person
meetings all over brazil right the idea
here the Internet in Brazil recognizes
diversity has one of its main principles
and to hold these meetings all over
Brazil was core of that recognition for
that path one thing that the Porto aims
to is actually to have transparency on
what was actually adopt by the reporter
and I think this is really important
when we have this crowdsource
effort of drafting legislation is to say
if this app has we say in in Brazil
write bread and circus or is this
actually impacting or something right
and they the choice made by the
policymakers who actually to map in a
series of reports and statistics what
was actually incorporated in the bill
that were coming from common citizens or
law experts or tech or the community or
even the companies they state a
stakeholder the business sector right
and it's really interesting to see that
they actually measured and put that very
transparency which type of contribution
was made so this was just some examples
of the contributions accepted but then
what happened right it was almost five
years already and tons of postponed
votes for Marco's view Marcos if it was
not being approved the biggest challenge
there was the lobby by the business
sector on the net neutrality issue there
was already a compromise with the
content industry that still happen old
politics still happened no matter the
process you engage but the transparency
really allowed us to see what was
happening in which were the interest is
that
but with these no different revelations
as you see Juma actually our president
understood that even her personal emails
were being surveilled and we also passed
three economical surveillance in the
case of Petrobras and other major
companies in Brazil and she decided to
negate a visit to us and she for the
first time get engaged in the Marcos
negotiations and I think that without
the support without this event a lot of
things would not have happened as fast
and not that one thing is consequence of
another but it was a tipping point to
generate her Warner's to the top
politicians above the ministries that
was that this was really important and
this was also a tipping point for the
whole society also to get engaged if you
saw we had a lot of protesters in Brazil
at the end of the beginning of this year
and a lot of folks engaging those
protesters were folks engaged in the
Marco Seaview advocacy at the grassroots
level so you see that same folks trying
to create and generate awareness of the
topic in those protests so finally in
March 23 around 23 we got the mark
receive you've approved in the House of
Representative I got super-drunk that
they was like there is a I got super
drunk and had to do alone my husband had
put our century sleep so there was
drinking a whole bottle but
understanding how you see for me it was
like finally you know and that the world
leaves your back because was such a
curve and a long curve of learning for
civil society and for experts that a lot
of people called Network the democracy
right and a lot of people called
horizontal with center cases on the
grassroots and and they call
transnational horizontal de vacas and a
lot of people call vertical democracy
when you have also Lobby involved and
all that happened
in Brazil all the concepts you can think
of advocacy happen in the making of
Marco's view and it is amazing to
understand how important as we were
discussing the last panel was to bring
this new generation and understand which
skills these people and their
organization had should be inserted in
one of these in this pyramid of of
tactics that actually brought about
democracy view a lot of they actually
they meet the social media democracy
happening this last six months or one
year before democracy was approved
before that we could say that we just
had the vertical type of a democracy
working on giving expertise and text to
the bill but without the grassroots or
result of advocacy I think that would
never achieve the moment of people going
to the streets you have that approved
this other intervention here was during
the netmundial meeting which was a
multi-stakeholder meeting in Brazil last
April to discuss a principles for the
internet again I think Marcos view
really inspired the outcome document
here because the outcome document is
based on a human rights frameworks a
really interesting document to say that
the public interests should be at the
core of any internet regulations and
again there was a intervention that time
there is no than a moment and and
significance for all that
and here was Dilma signing democracy
view on on on the on April 24th this
year and was really interesting for me
because I had the Cubans on one side
actually I was there so I had the Cuban
delegation on the one side and then the
South Korea delegation on the other side
and I was crying and the guys were
looking at me and was a really
interesting moment to see also everybody
applauding and the Russians and the
engines not applauding but that's
another story we can talk about but
anyway so what moment we are here in
Brazil we are in the moment of rings
letter and repeat because now giome
aurelius you
this possibility of social participation
to develop law in Brazil we actually
just approved last week law that enhance
ways for people to participate in
decision decision-making so is a
participative government we call and she
said that the Marcos review will also go
through this process because we now we
have to regulate right the real fight
now is the regulation here and one of
the bigger fights here it's gonna be on
the net neutrality side and also on the
privacy side because we have a privacy
data bo coming out of Brazil pretty soon
so I think these are some really good
examples of indentifying one case all
types of possible tactics afford vocals
you can have out there and looking at it
now to see exactly the strategy that was
behind all of that and I really like
this bath Novack coat that I actually
got from a hitter's document post saying
that these models need to encourage
participation has a lifestyle not just a
periodic engagement so I really hope we
all think through this conference how we
can always engage the next generation
independently of the technology we're
gonna have and debate true we're gonna
have what is need that you always have
those people on board should make that a
lifestyle and we are talking about
people not just technology here so
that's my message for now thank you
[Applause]
so Carol the good news is that not only
is it still 0-0 but actually Brazil have
all the shots on goal so far and
camarones picked up a foul
so just we're keeping an idea eye on it
for you look mark mark receive is
incredibly important it's been one of
the most hopeful moments for those of us
who would like to see the internet
really used as a platform for drafting
legislation as a way of building
movements but not all of us are
necessarily going to get involved with
questions of how we draft legislation
the good news is that there's a lot of
other issues that people can get
involved with in ways in which the open
Internet is making this possible and
with that in mind I'm really happy to
bring to the stage an old friend of mine
Renata Avila Guatemalan human rights
lawyer the head of creative commons
guatemala now the head of the web we
want project for the web foundation and
really a remarkable individual who's
leading a tremendously important project
as we head towards the 25th anniversary
of the web so please Renata
okay okay I cannot start discussing the
open web and all this conversation
without mentioning battle because my
friend muscle catabolism stay open web
to me and bustle is a love friend of
mine a love friend of many who is in a
prison in Syria because he dare to
create an open space to make the wave
happen in Damascus so please if you have
a chance please tweet something say
something and try to advocate and never
forget him and Allah and so many
activists who are in similar situation
but that's it and before starting my
conversation about the way we want I
want to mention something because in the
past like to talks the panel that we had
here we had this issue with the women
issue and I hate that is a women issue
you know that is a separate topic I hate
how we are not aware we are not
embedding women as part of the
conversation how these gets how is still
not there even in one of the most
educated and aware is spaces that I have
participated in - and when Karolina was
at stage is explaining the unprecedent
wind that we had asked love and civil
society with the approval of marco
seville it made me remember that it
wasn't possible without the
participation of lots of women because
unlike the colder space they those
lawyers lodge / advocates and lawyer /
academic / activists are those who
involved lots of women are those who are
fighting everywhere everywhere to keep
the internet open and 3 so that's it I
will explain my initiative so
so basically talking with Sir Tim
berners-lee we were discussing all the
characteristics that make the internet
open free and accessible and so on but
we noted that there's a missing
component a component that is not there
in the design of the Internet and that's
is that the internet was a technical
concept was built without having human
rights at its core and now things like
the Marco Sibylla trying to like now
that the infrastructure is in place we
are trying to put the layer of human
rights at the very heart of the Internet
and that's what the way we want is
trying to do so we lounge the web we
want initiative last year at the UN
Human Rights Day and it was very
interesting because you know usually
tech issues are discussed in tech for
for us and the IDF and other conferences
and techno technology conferences but it
never takes a central place at the core
of the human rights debate but on the
fifth of December last year we made it
happen and we had a higher head of the
UN Miss Navi Pillay who's a human rights
a long time a human rights activist
saying ok it's time to move from the
worldwide wave to the worldwide Human
Rights wave it was the starting and we
used like it is true that the wave is
only 25 years but we said ok we have
this opportunity of to celebrate the
wave to create awareness and start the
conversation about human rights and the
web and as a result as as a result of
the celebrations of the 25th anniversary
of the web we had this amazing
outreach but you know it's just one day
it was just one celebration of more more
or less a week of celebrations and it
that's not enough because yes people got
the attention many many people
especially after the Snowden revelations
were quite aware of the
need of something else more than just
code and free regulation for the
companies and so even if we got all this
attention we are still struggling on how
to build a movement out of it so we
started the dialogue but how can we make
something as the last four decades
environmentalist movement has done to
create cities and awareness on why it is
necessary to engage and take some degree
of responsibility and keeping keeping
the web open and free so we are a group
of organizations with long history in
these issues struggling with design
problems and basically it's how to
overcome the gender barrier for example
how do we include 50 50 percent in the
conversations how do we create some
consensus in among very different
societies and very different cultural
approaches to the web and how to avoid
the app trap because while Marco Seville
was a wonderful process and very
interesting one it only involved
something like you know less than 1% of
the population in Brazil so less than
1.000 one percent of the population in
Brazil who are like millions hundred
millions over 100 millions and so how do
we how do we open a process that is
meaningful enough for all the people in
a country and around the globe so we are
building and it is it is it's very
challenging and I am skeptical myself on
how how we will do it and if we will
achieve something but I hope that we can
so we are building these powerful
alliance on among very strong actors of
civil society who are doing what they do
best the association of progressive
Communications who will celebrate the
25th anniversary next year is designing
a start
- not to replicate but try to nurture a
similar processes as the Marco civil
process in a strategic countries so we
are talking about helping Tunisia and
Algeria Philippines and other key
countries were there's something already
happening to promote a good practices on
the web mo Silla is providing not only
the tools but also bringing the geeks
with the open net Fellows program today
to the game article 19 and global
partners are bringing the expertise so
because many many things and is a
problem that Racine is facing now for
example in the global south even if you
have the willingness to implement the
right privacy policy or a great net
neutrality law you don't have the
expertise there you have the people who
will know the best way to implement it
because very technical issues and now
our Congress people I mean and even the
advisers is simply not there the
capacity so it's an ecosystem of
solidarity and each institution doing
what each institution and each
constituency do best to have a virtuous
circle where everyone helps everyone and
we have a large Advisory Committee we
this is the Advisory Committee which is
guiding their initiative and saying no
stop that's another good idea or what
about doing the following this or that
approach to make it happen the
initiative the way we want was
reformulation and a response of the
constant fire fire station approach that
we have to Internet issues because what
if you look 10 years back it was it has
been like reaction reaction reaction oh
there's a low a bad low here let's
protest against the law and let's bury
the law there's a bad measure here and
censorship okay let's do online protest
so they unblocked the side but we have
neglected the proposal we have neglected
the proactive approach that we have to
this
so we are trying also to engage
different sectors than the usual ones
because this is a very lonely space and
if you think even here but if you go
even more south if I think of my country
what Amala for example every time that
we are discussing net neutrality is a
table with ten people involved because
there cultural an arts space the human
rights and business space the
entrepreneurs that like even the
government they do not understand the
implications of having the ground like
this legislation in here so this is a
long-term proposal this is not just a
year of celebrations the year of
celebrations is the skills to get the
attention of the people and to frame
positively what the web has achieved and
whatever has meant to too many but it is
it is just the beginning of something
that we hope it will be bigger and we
have three pillars that we are working
with legal and policy measures that's
where the national Marco civils will
take place the user choice and trying to
build an effective movement and how we
are designing it and that's the point I
want to refer that sometimes in these
conversations including the micro civil
conversations there are very earrin very
middle-class very like you know very
city conversations so for the son of the
national dialogues and the any activity
of the web we want by design is 50% of
women included and it's 50 percent of
rural population involved that's
expensive yes but that's a priority for
us we cannot have a meaningful dialogue
and a meaningful space it is if we don't
implement by design measures to include
people because that's the way I want and
this is right now what we are doing in
general an overview of what we are doing
and moving from opposition to
proposition and trying to suggest good
and healthy policies for governments and
for different spaces in spaces to start
but now at the work with one initiative
we have another problem and this is
because Tim berners-lee said this and
then sorry this guy said this so this is
the this crazy idea that many many many
very visible people is mentioned in
everywhere of an global Internet Magna
Carta so this is placing us the way we
want in a very complicated position
because we were advocating for change in
the local to impact the global but it
turns out that many people is asking
also for a global to crowdsource where
everyone is saying what is the work they
want and which are the principles will
govern the Internet and to be honest for
the Internet Magna Carta I need your
help because I do not have any clue on
how this will take place without being
exclusive being a tool of exclusion or
be not a tool that's captured by
specific interests so if you have ideas
please come to me and let's let's
discuss and help me please and yeah we
are building a movement so I hope that
you join you join us
[Applause]
thank you so much Renata I just want to
emphasize that I know that Renata is
here in no small part because she really
is interested in this question of what
looks like a Magna Carta for the
Internet and how is this a document that
ends up being incredibly inclusive
reaching out to all sorts of different
populations I was thinking about how
radical that idea of 50% rural inclusion
ends up being when we think about how
getting involved people people in
internet dialogues from rural areas in
the developing world has been it's an
incredible bar to set for herself and
for a project and I really hope that
people will reach out to her and look
for ways to go forward we have two short
talks at this point both coming from
students of mine talking about some of
the work that we're doing at center for
civic media around this idea of how
might civics change if we took seriously
this notion that we had a free and open
Internet and so the first team we have
coming up is the promis tracker team we
have Chelsea barabbas we have Heather
Craig we have Alexis hope making her
second appearance on the stage today I'm
looking forward to hearing from all of
them welcome up guys
[Applause]
[Music]
mm-hmm hi I'm Chelsea
I'm Heather I'm Alexis so as even
mentioned we're going to share with you
a little bit about our experiences
working on the promis tracker project
which really focuses on building tools
and processes that are geared towards
enabling citizens to collect data and
monitor in an ongoing basis the progress
that their elected officials are making
on the promises that they've actually
committed to doing while in office okay
it's the green button right okay so the
concept for promis tracker was kind of
born out of a provocation that I think
Ethan kind of posed to us about kind of
the state of Elections that we see today
and many of the democracies around the
world which was that we have free open
and bad elections and in order to kind
of understand what we mean by that we
need to think about what actually role
like what role elections play in the
democracies that we have today elections
are really one of the primary mechanisms
that we have for enabling citizens to
hold accountable the elected officials
that they put into office so if our
mayor commits to improving the streets
in our neighborhood and then completely
neglects that we as citizens are able to
then ask him in favor of somebody that
we think is actually going to carry
through on what they say they're gonna
do so when we think about kind of the
biggest threats to actually election
serving this purpose in democracy we
often tend to think about election fraud
so politicians or political parties that
actually try to rig elections so that
they undermine kind of the the will of
the people during these elections in
recent years we've seen actually some
really great progress being done with
citizen groups actually starting to self
organize and monitor the elections in
their countries and really starting to
improve the transparency of elections
all around the world but at the same
time we're also seeing that elections
still don't seem to be very connected to
politicians performances in office so we
begin to ask ourselves how could we
actually start to extend some of the
positive benefits we've seen
of citizen monitoring actually be beyond
the election process to to the in
between spaces when politicians are
actually supposed to be doing what they
said they were gonna do as we started to
think about this we started to look
towards some of the other more inspiring
projects that are going out there for
citizen data collections particularly
like within the environmental space
we're where organizations are designing
cheap and really accessible tools for
enabling citizens to really engage with
their environment and measure you know
sound pollution the quality of the water
things like this so we we started to
think about how could we use one of how
could we build off of one of the more
accessible technologies that's kind of
on the rise around the world today which
is mobile phones we over the last six
months or so have been designing a
mobile app that that we piloted for the
first time in in Brazil in January we
chose Brazil because it was a really
great opportunity for us to test this
mobile application into really different
contexts so one of the places wasn't Sao
Paulo where we were working with one of
the biggest grassroots civic
organizations in the country and
actually in the months just leading up
to us going there
notice how Paulo had actually mobilized
ten thousand citizens within the city to
identify a set of goals that the mayor
had committed to implementing during his
time his office so we had a great
environment with a clear set of goals
that we could actually test and these
goals ranged from healthcare related
things to parks and the arts very very
diverse the other partners we had was
actually not a citizen group it was the
government the state government of
Minister I they were really interested
in seeing the potential of using this
from the government side and actually
being able to engage their citizens
within around kind of the progress they
were making while in office so we
conducted two initial design workshops
with our local partners in Brazil one in
ministry and one in sub holo
and each of these workshops follow the
same basic three-part structure so first
we started by identifying parties to
monitor
and then we collected data on Android
mobile phones and lastly crafted data
presentations tailored to specific
audiences so day one of the workshop was
basically about identifying community
priorities and participants in the
workshop selected government goals to
monitor and in Sao Paulo we had this
fairly unique situation that Chelsea
just touched upon briefly where we had a
set of over 100 government goals that
the city of Sao Paulo it committed to
carrying out and and so on the first
evening of that workshop participants
went through these goals and chose the
ones that they were most interested in
monitoring in mean astride a different
scenario so we had participants
brainstorm issues and infrastructure
that they were interested in monitoring
and they thought could be improved in
their community and then we filtered
these to the most relevant seven or
eight that could be monitored in the
next couple days of the workshop so
after identifying priorities our team
collectively created custom data
collection forms for Android phones
using a platform called open data kit
and we loaded these forms on to the
mobile phones and on the next day of the
workshop participants winning of their
communities and gather data on the
issues they'd identified on day one
after collecting data everyone brought
back the phones and we uploaded the
content and print it out not all but
some of the content so photos and maps
and then in groups participants in the
workshop created data presentations and
presented their findings back to the
group and the data presentations I this
idea derives from the work of our whole
Bhargav who you heard from this morning
with his data therapy work so we learned
a lot from these workshops which has
taken back with us and is informing the
direction of our project since so the
the first big thing we learned as
Heather mentioned on the first day we
sat down with a group of folks and
talked about what the needs and
priorities of the group were and we
found that while people cared about
monitoring
concrete quantifiable things like
instances of trash not being collected
they also cared a great deal about very
complex thorny problems things like the
quality of education and government
housing approach appropriation things
that take a little bit of creativity to
figure out how to measure and so we
found that people are really interested
in documenting the stories of their
neighbors
so not just quantifiable things specific
data points they wanted collection forms
that offered more than just geolocation
and take a photo and answer a question
they really wanted to interview their
neighbors and surface those stories so
as we move forward we're thinking about
how to integrate those stories into the
presentation layer a promise tracker the
second thing we learned is that there's
no one-size-fits-all data collection
form so where as you can see like
there's lots of people who want to
monitor education but when you talk to
them there's very different ideas of
what specific data should be collected
so that's informing what we're building
over the summer which is a web tool that
lets citizens easily build these data
collection forms based on their own
interests they can share them with a
community that they want to collect data
with and then they can use that
information in whatever way that they
choose so we're really interested in
scaffolding process with this tool and
not just offering another tool to build
a data collection form so we're thinking
about things like how do you help people
decide what data to collect how do you
help them decide who they want on their
team collecting data and then how do you
help them decide what they want to use
that data for because you don't have a
reason to use it there's really no
reason to collect it so here you can see
the citizen is invited to choose an
issue to monitor and then here they're
asked to define their campaign goals
this is an area where scaffolding is
really important so we're trying to
think of good ways to help people define
what their campaign goals are because
it's very tricky then they can add
different elements to the forums like
GPS and photo video clip and drag them
around change it and preview the form on
an android phone simulator before they
share it widely with anyone so they can
make sure it's really what they want to
collect and then lastly they can sync
that data with our site to see some very
simple visualizations like
Matt for instance but also export the
data to other sites that offer web data
visualization tools because we want to
we don't want to reinvent the wheel and
we want to make sure that we're making
good use of all the other data
visualization projects there aren't
there so thank you so much if you're
interested in talking more about this
come find us at one of the breaks and
also Ricardo kata Waukee from the minas
gerais state government is here today so
if you see him say hello without him the
workshops would not have been possible
thank you please don't let the
professionalism and polish of these
remarkable young women fool you into
thinking that this is anything other
than the beginnings of a huge ambitious
project that we are still figuring out
so one of the reasons we're sharing it
is we really do want to have
conversations with people about where
we're going with this we are looking for
something as ambitious as a framework
for communities everywhere to find ways
to monitor powerful institutions we do
understand just how giant and how scary
a project that is on the other hand the
more we've dug into it the more we
realize how much there really is a need
for it and I've just learned a ton on
this project and particularly from from
from the three students we have on stage
here so thank you so much and now
closing out this session we have another
terrific student from center for civic
media who's been working on a master's
thesis and I'm not even gonna tell you
what it's about because Erhard is gonna
tell you all about action paths take it
away hi I'm Earhart from the Center for
civic median for the past few months
I've been developing a prototype Android
app and also a theoretical argument for
location-based civic engagement and what
I'm calling civic reflection the app is
called action path and I'll start by
telling you a little bit how it works so
imagine you work at MIT and you walk
over to Kendall Square to catch the 85
bus home to Somerville as you approach
the bus stop you actually step into a
geofence a kind of GPS hotspot and this
allows action paths
send you a push notification on your
phone alerting you to an opportunity for
civic engagement specific to that
location as a busy adult you may not
find the time to attend a town hall
meeting or a design charrette but you
still have time to think about and
respond to an issue while you wait for
the bus perhaps you had heard about mi
c-corporations proposal to create an
East Campus gateway by the T head house
right there in the photo or / or
possibly you didn't either way you might
have an interest in how that's going to
happen since you walked through that
corridor every day and while it's fine
to see the architectural mock-ups on a
printed poster or on a website ideally
you would consider those options right
in the space where they are meant to go
and that's what action path is meant to
do so action path survey shows you these
two options one for a renovated MIT
press building next to a new transparent
T head house and another for a new much
narrower building that would go where
the press building currently exists you
could look from your phone back up to
the street while you're staying there
waiting for the bus back again thinking
about kind of you know what are some of
the aesthetic concerns you might have
maybe looking up for additional
information as to what's going on with
this this conversation currently and you
can make a choice and have your vote
submitted at this point action path
automatically subscribes you to updates
to that issue so that you can follow
what happens next and maybe re-engage
with it at a later stage it becomes part
of a portfolio of issues that you have
learned about reflected and taken action
on this question about the MIT East
Campus gateway was just one of five
actions that I created for a half dozen
Media Lab errs who volunteered to test
an early act action path prototype last
week I interviewed each of them after
they'd used the app overnight taking
their commute home and back looking for
design feedback but also probing for how
using the app made them think and feel
several testers noted how the app
inspired their curiosity about what
issues affected the places they lived
worked and commuted they were
disappointed actually when there weren't
actions tied to certain locations in
institutions which they cared deeply
about they wanted a way to participate
and be involved in
she's surrounding those things they
cared about they were also eager to
explore their cities more widely and
collect all the actions almost like
playing a game
several the testers felt that they
gained a heightened state of mindfulness
as they walked around their city as well
as a sense of agency in their responses
asked about the option to follow at the
end of each survey one tester said it
felt like not only did my voice matter
but I could continue on the issue if I
was interested I thought that was the
simplest easy way to get involved in
community it wasn't a high commitment
level it was just whether or not I
wanted to follow an issue so needless to
say I was encouraged by the positive
reception by the early testers they got
the idea of right away one tester told
me unprompted that the onus is always on
you to go to a meeting it's great to get
beyond that now there's a lot of bugs
still to work out many of which were
pointed out by my testers of course but
the core idea seems to resonate with
everyone I talk to and it's not just on
the side of the potential active
citizens that it resonates but on among
the cities and the organizations that
might devise and sponsor the questions
fed in action paths I've been having a
string of meetings with multiple Boston
area municipalities who are interested
in running prototype deployments this
fall of action paths working on real
issues affecting their cities real
planning concerns and connected to
problems that they keep telling me about
these problems of reaching out to young
and new citizens getting quality
feedback outside of town meetings and to
get enough responses on all of their
their protocols for surveys and
interviews in order to help inform
decision-making so at the beginning of
these conversations I have with these
potential partners I always argue my
vision and I get a little theoretical so
I'm gonna get a little theoretical with
you the key part of my argument is
inspired by a conversation Ethan and I
have been having over the past year
about what makes for effective
citizenship that is the ability to
effect change using whatever tools and
theories of change might work in order
to have that change happen we've been
reading Michaels sheds and a few related
scholars and looking at how their ideas
for new
models of citizenship might be adapted
for technology enabled efficacy
this led even to should sins mana toriel
citizen concept this concept motivates
the promise tracker tool which you just
heard about it also powers action action
path particularly when you view monitory
citizenship as the descendant of Jane
Jacobs classic idea of eyes on the
street now Jacobs the urban theorist and
sociologists used this as a method for
learning about what urban planning works
and doesn't but it was more than that to
her it was the practice of neighbors
looking out for one another building a
sense of collective trust and through
that knowing what was going on matching
this activity with mobile computing
gives us the recipe for what some have
called sousveillance grassroots power
through crowdsourcing one of these open
web ideas there is missing piece here
though for me and it's the reflection in
and on practice or what I'm calling
civic reflection when done in the midst
of this kind of civic work I argued that
this is necessary for effective
citizenship or else you were just an
extension of a data collection tool for
me this boils down to a social and
technical design problem for the work
that I'm trying to achieve with action
path we need to investigate the design
principles that make for civic
technology that makes acidic
technologies good for effective
citizenship fortunately I'm not the only
person working on this problem I can
build off others in this space and build
off them in kind of critiquing your
friendly competition way you know I
critique these these different projects
because I love them so you look at folks
like mine mixer and co-organized which
are great virtual Town Hall services
unfortunately for me they represent
these non mobile sites that you have to
go back to you have to remember to go
back to sometimes there's a reminder
email sent but it's not connected to
your daily life in a regular way
there's the 3-1-1 apps like SeeClickFix
and citizens connect these kind of
report a pothole services they certainly
utilize the affordances of smartphones
for mana toriel citizenship however the
definition of citizenship embodied by
their designs really emphasized citizen
as data collector rather than something
that challenges you to be more deeply
engaged part of that urban intelligence
industrial complex that
she was talking about earlier that said
street cred a companion platform for
citizens connect developed over at
Emerson College here in Boston adds a
layer of team collaboration and
competition to make the experience more
exploratory and playful which is what I
think is the only missing element right
now in text ISM which is a fantastic
platform doing a very similar form of
collaborative and and crowd-sourced
decision-making via SMS now this is all
to say that there is good work in this
space but that there is still more to do
there's still more to think about and
there's more to do with with regard to
applying these kind of more thoughtful
approaches to design that embody these
theories of change not just for not just
around issues that you want to change
but about citizenship itself and so
while we're talking about cases here on
this panel I also want to kind of put
forward a research agenda that I'm
hoping to fall over the next few years
so how well can a solution like action
path actually scale is there a
possibility that was some combination of
Civic technologies we can solve the
problems of adoption rates and
persistently small ends that come out of
technologies dedicated to civic
engagement whereby knowledge or KenKen
technologies like action path in and of
themselves represent ladders of
engagement whereby knowledge and a sense
of agency move citizens towards
so-called thicker forms of participation
to me these questions suggest a research
agenda of two parallel components which
I hope to pursue over the next few years
starting with action paths and ideally
in partnership with the community in
this room that cares deeply about civic
technology first I think we need to
continue to develop prototypes and field
test them like I'm planning to do this
fall with action paths in the cities
that I'm working in some of these will
be production quality like Emerson's
tools others will remain proofs of
concept both of which we should use to
convince major platforms like Facebook
Foursquare and Cora that there is value
in pushing out those designs to their
users I believe a core role we
researchers and Technology should play
in translating the open web to offline
participation is by working to make all
apps more civic rather than just making
more Civic apps simultaneously
we need to redesign civics education or
more accurately open up civic learning
to incorporate the practical and
sometimes playful meaning means by which
young and old can push for change models
of effective citizenship like mana
toriel citizenship rely on experience
and reflection like we were hearing
about what makes a challenge is doing in
Chicago in the previous panel it comes
down to knowing how to learn more about
issues affecting your world world and
how to find small ways to contribute
toward bettering that world one action
at a time in the end that's what action
path for me is all about so please wish
me luck on my pilot deployments I'll
wish luck on everybody else's and I
really would love your help in these
efforts in this research agenda thank
you
[Applause]